[Music]
beauty is a curse psyche thought as she
looked over the cliffs edge where she'd
been abandoned by her father she'd been
born with a physical perfection so
complete that she was worshiped as a new
incarnation of Venus the goddess of love
the real life human lovers were too
intimidated even to approach her when
her father asked for guidance from the
Oracle of Apollo the god of light reason
and prophecy he was told to abandon his
daughter on a rocky crag where she would
marry a cruel and savage serpent like
winged evil alone on the crag psyche
felt Sofia the west wind gently lifting
her into the air it set her down before
a palace you are home
she heard an unseen voice say your
husband awaits you in the bedroom if you
dare to meet him she was brave enough
Saiki told herself the bedroom was so
dark that she couldn't see her husband
but he didn't feel serpent-like at all
his skin was soft and his voice and
manner were gentle she asked him who he
was but he told her this was the one
question he could never answer if she
loved him she would not need to know
his visits continued night after night
before long psyche was pregnant she
rejoiced but was also conflicted
how could she raise her baby with a man
she'd never seen that night psyche
approached her sleeping husband holding
an oil lamp what she found was the god
Cupid who set gods and humans lusting
after each other with the pinpricks of
his arrows psyche dropped her lamp
burning Cupid with hot oil he said he'd
been in love with psyche ever since his
jealous mother Venus asked him to
embarrass the young woman by pricking
her with an arrow but taken as psyches
beauty Cupid used the arrow on himself
he didn't believe however that gods and
humans could love as equals now that she
knew his true form their hopes for
happiness were dashed so he flew away
psyche was left in despair until the
unseen voice returned and told her that
it was indeed possible for her and Cupid
to love each other as equals encouraged
she set out to find him that Venus
intercepted psyche and said she and
Cupid could only Wed if she completed a
series of impossible tasks first psyche
was told to sort a huge messy pile of
seeds in a single night just as she was
abandoning hope an ant colony took pity
on her and helped with the world
successfully passing the first trial
psyche necks had to bring Venus the
fleece of the golden sheep who had a
reputation for disembowelling stray
adventurers but a River God showed her
how to collect the fleece the sheep had
snagged on briars and she succeeded
finally psyche had to travel to the
underworld and convince Proserpina queen
of the dead to put a drop of her beauty
in a
for Venus once again the unseen voice
came to psyches aid he told her to bring
barley cakes for Cerberus the guard dog
to the underworld and coins to pay the
boatman Charon to ferry her across the
river Styx with her third and final task
complete psyche returned to the land of
the living
just outside Venus's palace she opened
the box of Pro subpoenas Beauty hoping
to keep some for herself but the box was
filled with sleep not beauty and psyche
collapsed in the road Cupid
now recovered from his wounds flew to
his sleeping bride he told her he had
been wrong and foolish her fearlessness
in the face of the unknown proved that
she was more than his equal
Cupid gave psyche ambrosia the nectar of
the Gods
making her immortal shortly after psyche
bore their daughter they named her
pleasure
and she Cupid and Psyche whose name
means soul have been complicating
people's love lives ever since
[Music]
you